c'est pas qui ne veut plus entendre
parler de la réforme des retraites mais
refusé de parler des retraites refusé de
parler des retraites
lorsque dès avant la crise mais a
fortiori avec la survenance de cette
dernière
l' équilibre des comptes et donc la
sauvegarde du système actuel se trouve
compromise serait irresponsable il
responsable madame il responsable
je suis comme vous je n'en doute pas
extrêmement attaché au préambule de la
constitution de 1946 et à la conduite
des politiques sociales comme ferment de
notre pacte républicain bien qui peut
dire ici de façon plus structurelle que
notre système de retraite que je connais
bien sûr lequel j'ai travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années est juste il ne l'est
pas il ne l'est pas alors je vais vous
dire madame ce que je compte faire je
vais vous dire ce que je compte faire
premièrement je vais ouvrir le dialogue
toutes les organisations syndicales
viendront discuter avec moi et c'est
heureux que nous ne soyons pas d'accord
avec certains d'entre elles peut-être
nous verrons bien
1 nous rouvrons le dialogue et nous nous
mettons d'accord sur une méthode et un
calendrier
deuxièmement je traiterai j'aborderai la
question des retraites dans un cadre
global la réforme de l'assurance chômage
elle aussi indispensable mais elle aussi
impacté par la crise et il serait
déraisonnable de ne pas tenir compte de
cet élément nouveau la relance qui sur
bien des sujets impact des
considérations qui intéresse les
partenaires sociaux la dépendance moult
fois reporté et que le président de la
république m'a demandé avec mon
gouvernement de conduire
nous allons avoir une approche globale
de ces sujets et s'agissant des
retraites
je proposerai aux partenaires sociaux de
très clairement distingué la réforme que
les spécialistes appellent systémique
la réforme de structure vers un système
plus juste et plus égalitaire pour nos
concitoyens sur lesquels la concertation
va reprendre et ensuite la question de
l' équilibre du système actuel sur
lesquels je demanderai également aux
partenaires sociaux
madame de me faire leurs propositions
alors même
j'appelle votre attention et celle du
sénat que le système paritaire existence
sur les complémentaires agirc arrco lui
même pour les mêmes raisons
confronté à une menace de déséquilibre
les conduira nécessairement à reprendre
le chemin de la négociation
nous n'avons pas d'autre choix madame la
présidente que de sauvegarder notre
système de protection sociale
adam le prix
[Musique]